Il était une fois aux portes du Japon
Pour la protection de la nature en plein air
moitié humain
S'il y avait un yôkai appelé la réduction de moitié, alors
On dit que l'homme crabe a un grand trésor.
j'ai eu
voler le trésor
Certains sont partis à l'aventure
n'est jamais revenu
Un jour une aventure
a décidé de partir à la recherche d'un trésor
J'ai pris ma décision et j'ai décidé de m'y tenir jusqu'à la fin
La route était longue, le canard mandarin que j'ai rencontré
Mené par un scarabée
Pour apprendre à combattre et à survivre au froid la nuit
Trésor de feu
Quelques jours plus tard
Après de nombreuses références, enfin
J'ai eu le goût de Crab Man
soit brave
Je suis entré dans cette saveur
Excusez-moi, allez, c'est
Combattre une peur profonde
Soyez prêt à mourir avec un étang
Avance et tu es un homme pour le pire
Je ne sais pas pourquoi on m'appelle
n'ai pas
facile à combattre longtemps et durement
Le jeune aventurier est enfin un homme crabe
Donc
Un jeune aventurier courageux
Le vieil homme devenu une légende du plein air
quel était ce trésor
trésor
La courge reconnaissante de Dieu
[musique]
La bouteille d'eau reconnaissante d'Uko est cachée dans ce
Pourquoi ne pas essayer le bokeh dur?
proton